l'argent
bonsoir soir alors tu as 40 ans et tu es
l'auteur de lucien est quand même le
personnage que tu as inventé tenait à
inventer d'autres me disant que c'est le
plus connu et c'est le plus célèbre
rockeur des années 80 c'est un succès
fou ce truc là tu en as vendu combien au
total d'albums de lucien maintenant je
tourne autour de cent mille exemplaires
par alba mal tu sais combien par album
12%
mais non ça ça me suffit amplement vie
bien alors en plus tu es le grand prix
d'angoulême en 92 et tu veux être le
président d'angoulême dont 93 ce sens
n'a pas d'être devenu une institution
je ne prends pas comme ça de maire
d'angoulême ont 84 maire d'angoulême
c'est pas ma cg et ils vivent alors
quand tu étais petit tu habitais côté la
porte d'asnières dans un hlm de la ville
c'est pas un taudis d'ailleurs mais
c'est qui qui donnait sur la zone
est ce que c'est ça sur la banlieue sur
la zone est ce que c'est ça qui t'as
inspiré est ce que quand tu dessines tu
revois ces images de l'époque m'a je
pense je pense un petit peu parce
qu'effectivement j'étais assez troublé
quand j'allais levallois s'était levé
loi que j'avais en face de mes fenêtres
et c'était vraiment à l'époque c'était
surtout des garagistes qui avait
beaucoup de départs de voitures qui
étaient complètement désossés et c'était
des toutes petites maisons à ses séries
cook
alors quand j'allais voir des copains là
bas je veux un petit peu la trouille il
faisait quoi ton papa et à maman
mon père est artiste peintre et l'est
toujours ah oui déjà eu un mauvais et ma
mère était un mendiant est elle aussi en
fait ma maison
des signes très bien et c'est toujours
très bien ça fait de la peinture est
amer peu élevés parce que tes parents se
sont séparés quand j'avais 5 ans ceci
est très bien passé ouais c'est bien
passé c'est pas pour ça que tous les
jeux dit allez chez le psychothérapeute
là je me renseigne si si enfin je sais
pas j'étais un enfant très timide
j'ai passé mon temps à dessiner dans la
piaule m'entendez jamais c'est qu'est-ce
qui fait peut-être mort patch destiné
tout le temps et c'est ma belle mère qui
s'est un peu inquiète et qui n'est pas
normal sans fin alors je racontais mon
week-end puis quand j'avais raconté
lequel n'avait plus rien à dire et au
bout de six mois vont mon père me dit
alors comment ça se passe jusqu'à écoute
ça se passe bien je suis assis dans un
courriel dans un autre et puis et puis
north pasqua jugé des trois mots comme
un effort par le lui ça coûte et à quel
âge tu es passé du loup que miner
c'est-à-dire écharpe imperméable aux
loups là bas les pattes d'eph les
cheveux longs et laisser les classes
en fait ça correspondait à mon entrée
directe mon entrée en faisant appliquer
ouais mozart za et c'est vrai que quand
j'étais en troisième au lycée en 68
j'étais au saint père ne m'a coûté cher
et le plus long que tu es les cheveux
c'est jusqu'où le plus long avant de les
perdre c'est jusque là un peu plus
qu'aucun un petit peu avant le coup et
déjà fait couper en quelle année ses
beaux cheveux ses beaux cheveux quand
j'ai commencé la bdl encore long
en 78 quand tu as vu arriver les pins
que tu t'es déjà vu tomber les cheveux
une histoire drôle c'est qu'une fois tu
voulais aller aux indes et avait un
copain qui avait été à ostende et qui
avait dessiné comme ça sur les sur les
trottoirs en tu t'es dit on va se payer
le voyage aux ânes comme ça c'était pas
tellement le fait d'aller aux hommes
parce que j'étais baba cool mais j'étais
pas ils pillent pas vraiment tripes mais
rogers environ chercher des plantes une
pour notre copain c'était vraiment un
paquet de pognon sans décret sur les
trottoirs donc après on était d'aller
tout une bande la basse côte est où les
le quai d'ostende
et puis on a eu un été mais tellement
pourri pleuvait tous les jours tu es une
relance bouffer les doigts à force de
frotter voilà on a gagné juste ce qu'il
fallait pour payer la piaule ouais
depuis pour revenir à paris pour entrer
et à vue aux formes kouassi tapage et
les instances
alors j'ai fait discret sur sa vie
privée mais on sait jamais c'est pas
grand chose de toi tu es un peu timide
comme ça un peu discret d'ailleurs
lucien et baissent pas beaucoup dans les
bandes a pas trop hein ça passe on
tourne d'abord inscrit alors s'il le
fallait le faire des chèques sont là